good morning Hank it's Tuesday so I just
turned 40 which you'll be unsurprised to
learn has led to a bit of existential
navel-gazing but not with the
conclusions that one might expect so
when I was younger not just like in my
teens but also through my twenties I
thought of adulthood as like an ending
like in my imagination human life was
this epic road trip that started when
you were born and ended when you reached
your destination adulthood and once you
arrived at adulthood you were never
allowed to leave to me adulthood meant
being weighed down with all these
responsibilities you have to mow the
lawn and take your kids to soccer
practice and pay your bills on time
because you care about something called
your credit score and from what I could
tell about adulthood these
responsibilities would sort of pin you
down and prevent you from growing or
changing and you would just become a
robot that fulfills obligations you know
I thought it was like an existential
death that came several decades before
your actual physical death so to delay
the onset of adulthood and the
metaphysical death that came with it my
strategy in my twenties was to keep my
life very light and lean like one time I
remember saying to a girl I was dating
that if I needed to I could pack my life
up into my car in 15 minutes she dumped
me shortly thereafter now of course I
couldn't pack up my wall of memorabilia
in 15 minutes let alone my whole life
and of course I'm gonna tell you that I
was under estimating adulthood because I
have to write adults can't think of
adulthood as a prison from which there
is no earthly escape we have to trick
ourselves into thinking that we're
having a great time and not at all being
slowly strangled to death by homeowners
association meetings and who knows maybe
I am tricking myself but for the record
I love being in a place that's hard to
leave I like having roots in a place and
friends I've known for 25 years and that
wasn't possible 20 years ago because you
know I hadn't been alive for 25 years
now sometimes I do feel overwhelmed by
the obligations of adulthood but even so
I would not want to be 15 again or for
that matter 25 I know that's easy for me
to say because I've been incredibly
lucky in both my professional and
personal lives but I know a lot of
middle-aged people who are leading a
wide variety of lives and I honestly
think that my experience is more the
rule than the exception adulthood is so
underrated but more importantly it turns
out that adulthood is not a destination
like I don't think my life has grown
less interesting as it has grown more
settled I used to think that nothing
stank of failure quite like living in
the suburbs with your spouse and your
two kids that such an existence was a
tremendous waste of what Mary Oliver
called your
one wild and precious life but I find it
40 that my life feels wilder and more
precious than ever that's not to say
that my way of being an adult is the
only good way or that it's right for
everyone it's just that it's right for
me and if this is 40 I'll take it
thanks so much everybody for their
birthday wishes and turtle cakes three
more things first look I have finished
signing all 200,000 copies and the boxes
are gone those 200,000 sheets of paper
are now at the printer in Virginia being
bound in two copies of Turtles all the
way down amazon and barnesandnoble.com
have both sold out of their allotment of
signed copies but there's still lots of
other ways to get them more info at
probably signed turtles calm secondly my
video next week will be me reading the
first chapter of turtles all the way
down that video will be over four
minutes but that is not punishable there
are precedent set in 2011 in 2008 when I
read the first chapters of The Fault in
Our Stars in Paper Towns and lastly I
want to say to our friends and viewers
affected by flooding in Texas and
Louisiana and also in India Nepal and
Bangladesh that we are thinking of you
nerdfighters if you're able I hope
you'll join me in donating to relief
organizations there are links in the
doobly-doo below Hank I will see you on
Friday